antonina entwickelt videospieler und
arbeitet bei dem studio fox in kiew für
das interview mit uns kommt sie zum
ersten mal nach monaten in die firma hat
ihre kollegen seger und sehr lange nicht
persönlich gesehen die belegschaft ist
komplett im home office doch auch zu
hause ist niemand sicher
manchmal kannst du nicht schlafen weil
du aufwachst und dich in sicherheit
bringen muss
manchmal passiert dass während du
arbeitest und du musst unterbrechen
dann schreibt jemand in den gruppenchat
wir haben hier luft allein und man
wünscht einander dass man sicher bleibt
trotz der täglichen bedrohung ist es
antonina wichtig weiter videospiele zu
entwickeln
meine arbeit ist die medizin die mich
davon abhält durchzudrehen
es fällt mir sehr schwer mich zu
konzentrieren
und die minuten in denen ich das schaffe
sind ein segen
die ukraine ein zentrum der europäischen
spiele industrie mit einigen tausend
entwickler innen eine geeignete
ablenkung sind die videospiele die im
land entstehen jedoch kaum das setting
häufig kriegerische konflikte
aber ein ventil um das zu verarbeiten
was die spiele entwickler innen in der
ukraine seit jahren erleben nicht immer
ist der krieg thema wie hier in das
ranking city das france 2009 10
veröffentlichte ein düsteres groteskes
horrorspiel mit einem detektiv als
protagonisten allen spielen gemeinsam
eine bedrückende stimmung
was hecking city wurde viel düsterer als
wir es geplant hatten das zeigt wie sehr
uns die situation in der ost ukraine und
auf der krim beeinflusst hat acht jahre
lang krieg das ist nichts was du mal so
eben vom tisch wischen kannst nichts mit
dem du fertig wirst und das zu vergessen
kannst du
auch in fantastischen szenarien wie in
das ranking city kann sich die harte
realität widerspiegeln die die spiele
entwickler innen umgibt und beschäftigt
so wie es auch in der literatur oder
malerei der fall ist
[Musik]
rund vier autostunden von der
ukrainischen grenze entfernt liegt
warschau das polnische studio eleven bit
hat rund 840.000 us-dollar an das
ukrainische rote kreuz gespendet
der erlös aus einer besonderen
verkaufsaktion ihres anti kriegs spiels
das worauf mein
videospiele mit klarer pazifistischer
botschaft gibt es bereits etliche
deutlich seltener solche die die gräuel
des krieges aus der perspektive von
zivilisten erzählen
ziel des spiels überleben lebensmittel
oder materialien sammeln sichere
schlafplätze finden manchmal auch auf
kosten anderer menschen
das worauf mein ist ein spiel das man
nicht gewinnen kann denn der krieg kennt
nur verlierer
die belagerung von sarajevo mitte der
90er das war der ausgangspunkt dieses
stets als nun der krieg in der ukraine
begann fühlten wir uns in der pflicht zu
handeln mit einer spendenaktion
des war auf meinen erschien erstmals
2014 und wurde mehrfach ausgezeichnet
inzwischen wird es auch am polnischen
schulen empfohlen als wichtige anti
kriegs botschaft ein spiel kann gerade
kriegsszenarien auf eine besonders
individuelle art vermitteln
wenn man über ein gedicht redet spricht
man über die intentionen der autorinnen
ein videospiel aber ist ein interaktives
medium es geht um deine entscheidungen
im spiel die tu geführt hast
das ist der vorteil von videospielen so
könnte letztlich auch ein videospiel das
den krieg in der ukraine
aus sicht der menschen erzählt ein
bedeutsames sein
es wird videospiele über diesen krieg
geben sie könnten geschichten über maja
opel hake vor der kirche oder natürlich
besser erzählen
sie könnten ein licht auf die verbrechen
werfen die hier geschehen sind
und so werden sich spiele entwickler
innen innerhalb und außerhalb der
ukraine wohl irgendwann dieses themas
annehmen denn auch ein spiel kann helfen
die traumata des krieges aufzuarbeiten
es kann sogar zum historischen dokument
werden und zu einem zeichen der
anteilnahme und solidarität
doch noch ist der krieg nicht vorbei
jedes mal wenn jemand außerhalb des
landes solidarität mit der ukraine
fordert wenn ich die gesamtsumme aller
spenden sehe oder eine gruppe leute die
zusammenkommt und an uns denkt all das
hilft mir dabei auf den beinen zu
bleiben
nach einer knappen stunde muss antonina
wieder nach hause auf sie warten noch
ein paar stunden arbeit oder bei
luftalarm der schutzbunker